When running my rife day program, there are times I can't sit and finish the entire program.
What should I do? Well, it's same as running your night program. Let's say your night program is
night hours long and you have to get up and go to work. It's, you know, the only red at seven hours.
Well, just turn it off and you'll get it tomorrow or those, how I write the night programs is they
recycle throughout the night. You know, they're not just, you know, what was in the, in the later part
of the program on Monday night might be an earlier part of the program Tuesday night. So you're not
going to miss those frequencies. The only times we've really shortened up people's night program is
when they were like, okay, this is you got them at these are night hour programs that I never have been
for more than five hours, you know, or some crazy thing like that. You should be sleeping more than
five hours. So I can shorten them up, but of course, when you shorten things up, you're getting less
time per frequency, which is a good. Now the day programs, they're not recycled in there. So let's say
it's a two-hour day program and you're only getting an hour of it. Well, then you're just going to get
an hour of it that at this time and you just will maybe next time you'll be able to do the whole
thing. So that's okay. So just do which can the day programs again are not required. Nothing's
required, but the day programs are just for when you are, you know, sitting and and have a chance to
sit and relax. You know, I tell people to try to create an environment at home where you can do
the rife when you're sitting watching TV or reading a book or something like that too. So you're
getting as much rife time as possible.